we did some research to find out the
income sources of different celebrities
and we're going to share that info with
you right now in a piece we're calling
[Music]
celebrity income rates it's part of our
program of annoying and embarrassing
celebrities yeah that's what we do we do
yeah first up let's look at Donald
Trump's income here's how it breaks down
15% of his income is real estate
investments that makes sense
15% Celebrity Apprentice residuals that
makes sense 70% secret payments from the
Hillary Clinton campaign fire this is
Kim Kardashian this is interesting Kim
Kardashian 60% comes from her TV show 30
percent comes from endorsements 10% is
sitting on things that need to be flat
[Applause]
songwriter ed Sheeran and he's very
popular right now 40% from digital music
sales 30% from touring and 30% gathering
golden rings
this out Rand Paul presidential
candidate Rand Paul's income at print
turns out it's 40 percent salary 30
percent investments and 30 percent
selling clumps of hair to repair old
Cabbage Patch Kid Larry King Larry
King's income 10% radio and TV
appearances 10% Larry King now online
show 80% residuals for inventing fire
[Applause]
[Music]
because he's very very very old Kanye
West Kanye West look at this fit 5%
concert and record sales 5% speaking
fees 90% please don't speak feet
former Volkswagen CEO Martin Winterkorn
10% is from retirement settlement 15% is
investments and 75%
nice job checks from James Bond villain
Senator Marco Rubio running for
president Senator Marco Rubio 65% US
Senate salary 5% interest from
investments 30% modeling for ash cash
for God horse Dustin Diamond remember
him from Saved by the Bell Dustin
Diamond
I didn't do it yet folks I didn't do it
yet let's assume that it's nice and
uplifting man what do they think of me
okay Dustin Diamond from Saved by the
Bell 50% Cannes 50% Bobby
Steven Tyler yeah Steven Tyler from
Aerosmith yeah they have 44% Aerosmith
residuals 34% live appearances and
performances 22% letting wealthy birds
use his hair as a B&B
you're probably wondering what's the
income breakdown for wealthy birds well
just gonna be a wealthy Birds it's 30
percent bird movies 30 percent bird TV
shows 40 percent killing wealthy worms
now now you're probably wondering where
do wealthy worms get their honey
well now that you mention it yeah well
wealthy worms 30% samaritans 30% coins
found in soil Wow 40% eating wealthy
protozoan
and now here's a pie chart not for
income but for our audience's opinion on
whether we should keep going further
down the food chain the audience said 34
percent say yeah what the hell go for it
22 percent said not sure man it's your
show
44 percent traffic out of Burbank could
be bad
let's wrap this
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography